they were allowed to kind of practice in
secret a URI product of your scene you
can't just have one really good player
and everyone else in your area is this
really bad
nobody knew just how good accent was our
salon - shows up at Evo and he wins and
then he's like you guys haven't seen all
the people I play with back home all the
Japanese were like what the hell those
for the flaw in the Pakistan the
practice and they're getting destroyed
by that being Evo champion is no small
thing and then I came back home every
children in my city normally this is
earth land fight the time look at the
time turn of follow up unbelievable the
lead Oh blows OH
that was a crazy trade Arslan cementing
his position as the best second player
on the planet untouchable
Pakistan is not a country where most
people are privileged enough to dedicate
their lives to something as frivolous as
competitive video games it's a country
locked in a tense nuclear standoff with
its neighbor it's a country where most
people live on less than $2 a day it's a
country that's difficult to travel to
and even more difficult to leave which
means that it's once secret Tekken scene
basically developed in a total vacuum I
just feel like in terms of exposure they
completely slipped under the radar and
it's it's the reason we don't know about
them but this also means that they were
allowed to kind of practice in secret
you know kind of come in with the stylus
surprised everyone just no one was aware
you know traditionally Tekken has been
dominated by Korean and Japanese players
with only a handful of American and
European players rising up to challenge
them but that's only happened because
players from those regions could easily
travel to compete amongst the game's
best Pakistan's Tekken players didn't
have that luxury they really left the
country to practice leaving the scene
without many opportunities to train
against the world's best players and
because they didn't travel no one knew
about them for years the secrets of the
Pakistani Tekken scene were passed
around as rumors but most people just
thought they were the empty boasts of
proud expats at UCLA law school there
were a lot of foreign students and one
of them was a law student from Pakistan
he would always tell me like look these
players seem good but you got to see our
players in Pakistan all right buddy
and he was absolutely right in
retrospect Arslan Arslan - Sadiq showed
up in 100 ug 2018 but he didn't just win
in the grand finals he defeated bei knee
jae-min better known as the god of
Tekken before that moment almost no one
outside of Pakistan had heard of Arslan
- but they were about to
Arslan ash started his career playing
King of Fighters before making the move
to Tekken heroes through Pakistan's
Tekken ranks pretty quickly facing
incredible talent the rest of the world
I quite literally never seen let alone
heard of a dude who came in Tekken 6 to
the UK it was awesome and when he came
down we were very surprised in the in
the UK scene we thought we were really
good and this dude from Pakistan came
and just destroyed everyone and we're
like what the hell you know in order for
someone to be as good as he he is and he
was it means that you're seen in your
yeah you're seeing your local scene must
be really good as well
URI product of your scene for him to say
that someone is really good and I'm not
even the best in Pakistan there are
people who are way better than me
yeah I definitely believed and then when
he could finally leave the country to
face off against the talent the world
didn't know he showed them a style of
Tekken they didn't even know existed
Arslan ash arrived to ebook Japan after
a hellish travel experience he arrived
at the venue minutes before pool started
I said to my sponsor that I am leaving
home this book me a ticket from here to
Lahore because there were only four hour
left for the tournament and I went to
the counter and he said and I said
there's a flight from here to Fukuoka in
about one hour so I told the my sponsor
he booked me - fly and what for that
like when I went to the Fukuoka finally
there was no money and I have no money
to grab a taxi
I have money the money was in Pakistani
rupees not in Japanese yen against all
odds are Celyn made quick work out of
some Tekken's best but because he was
relatively unknown most of his matches
were played off stream and by the time
they broadcasted his matches he'd
already beaten the likes of nee Chanel
and Rickster but his first game on
stream then came against the defending
Evo champion low-high like I said before
stop that you were in a party you guys
asked them to come to the stream here we
go we'll end up Caudill well I went
without risky pairings
oh this rally oh my god to mix up the
community so confident first game -
Arthur although the amo champ oh I still
in it
what's he gonna do the throw is tech
like trying to stay alive tournament
life on the line here 1 1 2 with the
whip when it's on the throw Ocelot
eliminates low high Marceline's reign of
terror continued as he took down book
Jimmy J Tran Chico den and CherryBerry
mango before facing a K in the grand
finals man on fire three rounds straight
pinkies in trouble I'm calling it right
now dude this poor L straight long
things are working out then the wall
slap it up you can't hog kick this man
the punch - pigs looking here men Arslan
act is up now five rounds straight here
in this matchup against our saloons
victory at Evo Japan was an incredible
moment the Pakistan on the map and yet
there were still some out there who
doubted his win they didn't think it was
a fluke but they believe that our
saloons Pakistani style of Tekken would
soon be figured out by the Korean gods
[Music]
and as part of that process NIDA clared
he wanted to train in Pakistan a lot of
people didn't believe that serious and
then you know says someone replied to me
are you serious and then chanel replied
saying does it look like he's joking and
I spoke to him and he was actually
saying to me yo swag I want to go
Pakistan where should I go where are all
the players which city knee is a tekken
legend in fact his nickname is literally
the god of tekken with the tournament
record spanning over a decade
competitive play he's won countless
championships played dozens of
characters and his legacy is untouchable
he was also the defending evo Japan
champion and being knocked out off
stream by a guy no one had ever heard of
before made him hungry but not for
revenge for self-improvement the
Pakistani scene was saying that it said
big honor because at the end of the day
he's a legend probably the greatest of
all time and you know to have him say
hey I wanna go to Pakistan to learn how
to be better in second I mean what
better complement man unfortunately
something got in his way
unfortunately there was a little bit of
conflict between India Pakistan
so it was advised by you know foreign
foreign governments say hey maybe you
shouldn't go to Pakistan right now is
quite dangerous but when Arslan went
back to Japan after the Japanese Tekken
scene challenged him to a series of
first two tens he packed his bags and
hopped on a plane to Osaka Arslan took
down every single Japanese player he
played but knee proved tougher
[Music]
- kaboom nyan Arslan played three first
two tens for a total of 47 games most
about hustling machine in the end while
knee won the series two-to-one Arslan
one more individual games 24 - nice 23
neither could lay claim to being better
than the other but knee the god of
Tekken learned that there was more to
the game he been playing since he was a
child I I was alone different it
thinking different thinking yes you know
you learn my stuff yeah
Oh different style
[Music]
after evo japan Arslan anni met again in
thailand at first it seemed like their
matchup was faded with both coming into
the top eight from the winners bracket
but while Arslan defeated his
first-round opponent two to one knee
fell to his losing 2 to 0 but knee
wanted a rematch with his newfound rival
he tore through the losers bracket
beating no be ranked choo and Ulsan
before earning another showdown with
Arslan tiger uppercut 2019 and from
Pakistan Arslan ash over Nia grand
finals Arslan had once again beaten knee
in an official tournament match but this
time it was on stream and the entire
Tekken world saw him do it
Tekken World Tour 2009 TV doesn't they
keep truck
no one shut the hell up no one is even
trying to even think about writing this
guy off at this point maybe the first
time maybe the second time but by now
you already know he's not even fighting
as a challenge or anyone's fighting as a
champion Arslan had defeated his rival
yet again but there was still one last
crown left to earn one last Kingdom left
to conquer the next month Arslan finally
managed to make it to the US for the
first time but he only did that with the
help of the community getting to Japan
at the beginning of the year required a
complicated visa process but the u.s.
was another thing entirely
luckily the community rallied behind him
'if I pass a program designed to raise
money for and assist with visa
applications for foreign players looking
to get to the US got him a visa through
the community's efforts our Celyn made
it over to north america for the very
first time
Evo the biggest fighting game tournament
in the world a year ago Arslan showing
up at Evo and trying to win would have
seemed laughable to anyone who didn't
know his story but before Arslan could
prove himself a evo there was another
challenge to overcome at the world
showdown of esports tekken invitational
Arslan was forced to forfeit his first
match to anakin due to travel delays
putting him in the loser's bracket he
made it to the venue in time for his
first loser's bracket match one that
many assumed he'd win but Arslan had to
play Jimmy J Tran one of North America's
best Tekken players and he was not about
to let Arslan take over his turf without
a fight rage mode now bail progress if
you can land a rage Drive you can't get
to the wall very easily you got to watch
out against Kazumi looking for a duck
right there as a back won a rarity to
the scene move to the commotion flying
around Jimmy J twin Arthur Nash loser
bracket action someone's going home the
levels are rising again oh oh
life is about even now let's go Jimmy
Arsenal's loss created some doubt in the
community maybe America's style of
Tekken was the answer to our saloons
defense
maybe the Pakistani style was just part
of a wider international rock paper
scissors maybe Arslan and nice showdown
wasn't destiny after
all our salons run through the first few
chunks of Evo's massive bracket were
uneventful Swift often on streamed wins
over unknown Evo hopefuls then he blew
through again team liquids prodigal Tech
and talent and cuddle core one of n A's
most beloved players after that he was
just two wins away from the table eight
first came shadow this is a tough spot
for shadow right now on the corner not
good at the rage expended I got used it
to get out but I mean yeah he can't take
a single hit anymore using these foes
are some crime is a factor - up back
three souls solid from our slip then
neuroma one of Japan's best players
nobody didn't expect that at all so I
ducked it just didn't do anything
flashed up their pump in a low parry one
more fireball just move that over
that'll pull up we went for mix-up oh
what a block and punish our Celyn ass
will be our final top eight competitor
in the winners side at this point all
doubt was gone his loss to Jimmy J Tran
wasn't a fluke it was just a learning
experience by beating neuroma Arslan
qualified for top 8 in winner side on
Sunday he would play in front of the
world on the biggest stage fighting
games have to offer but on the other
side of the bracket knee was on a
warpath one that ended with his faded
showdown against Arslan once again a
chance for each to prove their skills
not for the world
before each other but it's very hard to
accept this is gonna hurt and he's
capitalizing big time won't break all
the way oh my god he's the mayor
regarding how amazing didn't get to use
the Mexican at all
but it doesn't matter oh he's just
doubled up these guys corner oh my god
ed no he missed it oh my gosh what's
gonna happen so close
wow he's almost ready h2 that's all my
girls will punish you got a huge mistake
there and it's gonna cost it it is gonna
cost him oh oh but arson - fighting back
big lead Oh blah that's the block he was
looking for our slant takes the lead in
the set oh my gosh if an arson ass is
looking really good cuz he's an [ __ ]
shrink over here one more mix up to do
it he gets them in and this is knees
last opportunity here to break this
curse the whole stuff is coming any
moment now
there it is he blew it the time oh the
mix-up what's you to do there's no time
look very believable the time look at
the time gotta follow up unbelievable
the lead
it was a close match but in the end our
salons defense proofed too much for knee
but knee ripped through the losers
bracket
bringing down Nobby Oh taki oh wow and
in a nail-biting ly close match Anakin
all to earn a spot in the grand finals
all to face Arslan ash one last time the
two players everyone has been talking
about all year long
yeah it's me versus are slanted I mean
it's really fitting this is the way it
was written 1900 players were down to
two isn't that amazing it is that these
two it is crazy isn't that crazy cuz
this is the match of that a lot of
people were calling out either dread
find it yeah it's just like written that
way in stone destiny was fulfilled
Arslan against knee and the grand finals
Korea against Pakistan rival against
rival decides that parsley always keep
it on the ground
oh what a will punish and the devil
comes out and like we said once you find
that opening it's your job to fill it
and he just did besides that block going
right every time
oh what a footage he's got rain is gonna
recently at the wall are rain
it's gonna hurt oh wow
incredible what Mars our slam Nazi
buffet see oh man oh man isn't it so
weird for me being the underdog and not
just the underdog by this much good so
weird
I've made the pressure look at this you
can just wheel tomorrow away ass right
now steel paddle here's a man on fire
and again oh jeez he created a little of
trade yep okay the meetings over 200 my
god full damage look at that damage oh
wow that was sick what a finish walk
left there for community facing red
stuff and look at that perfect look at
me have you ever thought that knee would
look like this it perplexed as to how to
beat his opponent and he is widely
considered is the best second player of
all time of all time
Oh step Oh
el Diablo he's committed it's never
happened in the history of competitive
Tekken someone to come out of nowhere
Pakistan and dominates the entire Korean
Japanese European and North American
scene all been allocated you guys
there's over two hundred thousand people
watching right now and this is of course
record covers for this
look at these Oh God thank you so much
everybody for joining us but we're gonna
need your help if me is to stay alive
here he's getting blown out he has a
lead tents wandering or the foot army
great rage is a huge deal here Wow look
at me look at me look at the crowd Oh
God
how did he make that happen what's gonna
happen right now he lookin for this
opportunity to you holding my breath oh
they train blows OH
Oh
that was a crazy trade Arslan cementing
his position as the best second player
on the planet untouchable by any country
that we have seen thus far very very
nice
so back is in a dike city very like I
said you can't even counter that no way
Carson ask your ebook yeah channel work
our saloons win moved him to pray you
know of course paying respect I love
what I'm seeing
beautiful they knew how hard he worked
how far he'd come and they knew what
this wing represented has never been so
blessed
I'm so happy our saloons win was more
than just another tournament victory it
was a win for Pakistan nobody knew just
how good pax then was the region
arseling ash shows up at Yvonne he wins
and everybody's like okay this our salon
- guys pretty good it's you know it's a
big win that's pretty wild and then he's
like you guys haven't seen all the
people I play with back home he's like
you think I just came here and I'm this
good there's so many incredible players
in Pakistan as a reason it's also a win
for the rest of the world
proof that Tekken isn't just dominated
by Korea Japan and the US proof that if
you can find a way to travel if you
think you're good enough you can win the
biggest tournament in the world I do
think this is a good learning experience
for everyone don't just focus on who
people tell you to keep your eyes open
look around maybe you'll learn something
new it's cover
an Evo champion in the making and
finally our saloons win is a win for
Tekken it's an inspiring story that's
sure to get more people from all over
the world playing the game traveling to
tournaments and creating even more
stories
Arslan returned home to a hero's welcome
in Pakistan he was greeted with flowers
in the airport and even made the
national news service target engine a
box and a gamer or solana it's the
dengue nostalgia you do giving
championship evil friendly 19 but there
are killers just as good as arson still
in Pakistan who haven't gotten a travel
his winner sparked a few Pakistani
players to sign with form orgs but true
change takes time
Pakistan isn't quite a Tekken powerhouse
just yet but their day is coming soon
because Pakistan gave the world Arslan
ash and Arslan ash paid them back with
good ass Tekken thanks for watching if
you want more content like this hit the
sub button and ring that notification
bell for unique bite-sized videos you
will find anywhere else hit up our
Instagram Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]